all right hey everybody uh thanks for
joining the our studio youtube live for
today we're gonna get started here in
just a few minutes um i'm gonna be going
through quite a few different slides and
we'll be having a lot of fun today
so we'll give some folks a couple of
minutes um we started maybe 30 seconds
early so give folks a little bit of time
to to roll in but thank you so much for
joining me today my name is tom mock i'm
going to be your your host for today
i'll be sharing some links and some
comments in the chat so if you do have
any questions feel free to post them
there
let me know how things are going and if
you have any issues with the live stream
part of what i like from last time was
at the start everyone kind of gave a
shout out to where they're joining us
from you don't think of the exact
location but just kind of uh you know
the city or even the state or the
country you're joining us from
all right let's give it a few more
minutes we're at the top of the hour for
me here in texas it's about 10 a.m so
we'll give it a couple more minutes to
kick off
and then we'll uh head over and have a
good old time
all right
okay all right so we've got a good
amount of people in the room i'm going
to go ahead and start screen sharing my
desktop and we'll jump into it so for
today we're going to be going over our
studio team which is one of the
professional products and kind of the
overall software suite that our studio
provides
you probably know our studio from the
self-named rstudio uh ide or integrated
development environment and that's one
of the core things we produce in
addition to all the free open source
software that we provide
now we have to you know make money to
kind of give away a lot of the things we
create so we also sell professional
products that enhance some of the open
source work that we produce and give
away and so that's what we'll be talking
about a little bit today as well as how
the open source work can integrate
inside of it
so i'm going to share my desktop real
quick and we're going to go a little bit
off script to start
um
you may be familiar with what is the
rstudio ide so this is you know
just looks like any old rstudio ide
session
the benefit being that kind of for what
i'm doing today i'm actually running an
rstudio workbench so you'll notice that
i'm working through a browser as opposed
to my desktop
and a couple other things that i'll be
covering today
now while i could walk through for an
hour and kind of to show you the ide um
i do want to have some slides to work on
so let's let's knit some slides we can
create a quick uh sharingan presentation
that i can actually talk about for today
so
here are slides we'll let those load up
for one second
all right well that's great so we got
our studio team but i don't want to
share from this browser i'd rather
actually
share it from some place where y'all can
actually see it as well
so i'll take this file and let's confirm
that i'm working on the latest one okay
so this was created about 20 seconds ago
great
let's take that file and we're just
going to deploy it to our studio connect
so in about five seconds i went from
working in my environment to having this
hosted on our studio connect and now i
have a url that anyone can access it
anywhere in the world
so these slides are now up at
colorado.rtstudio.com
rsc
rstudio dash team dash prez
so now you can go actually look at these
slides and follow along with me
so let's go to that i'll go to the
actual slides for day and we'll jump
into that if someone from the other
studio team could drop that link in the
chat that'd be fantastic
so rstudio team a single home for r and
python for all the data science teams
again i'll have the slides linked at the
very bottom and you can walk through all
of that
part of what we're covering today is the
hard truth that data science is really
hard
and it can be challenging to kind of get
value from some of the work you're doing
or get you know executive buy-in or
business value from what you're doing
so in many cases many data science teams
actually fail to live up to what they
promise or what they want to deliver
because there's these challenges or
these kind of uh momentum that they have
to fight against
so what we've done with our studio team
is try and solve some of these problems
and first let's kind of talk about the
problems or the the barriers that data
science teams might face and then we'll
talk about how we can work to solve
those
so first off data science teams find it
difficult to create insights or impact
decision making or find it difficult to
create maintain and improve their data
products their models their apis their
applications over time
there's a lot of different ways that
this shows up in terms of it could be
difficult to recruit data scientists
because you're using a very specific
proprietary tool
or you don't have all your data
connected
for decision making maybe your
stakeholders just don't understand the
insights or there's a long you know
duration between what if this happens or
what if this happens and they actually
answer that question
it's also often difficult for teams to
build on previous work for new use cases
they basically have to reinvent the
wheel every time rather than kind of
building off previous work
also they might have analysis
constraints or delays imposed by some of
those proprietary tools
this can lead to slow iteration which
hinders alignment between the business
unit and the data science team
or even irrelevant or outdated insights
because things have been slowed down
additionally this can lead to insights
become obsolete or difficult to
reproduce
again the reproducible reproducibility
kind of
tenant of our studio
is true for both academia and for
business settings
and then lastly siloed teams often lead
to redundant work and there's lack of
crap collaboration
with too much time just spent like
maintaining the tools or the difficulty
of maintaining data science environments
lastly you know teams can't often
self-deploy so they have to like go ask
it can you take this and run with it or
hand it off to a new team and there's
this disconnect between what you're
actually creating and getting it into
decision making or getting it into
production
and this is kind of lastly pointed out
by just too much manual effort you know
you're not able to rerun your analysis
or not able to maintain that you know
the work that you're creating
so part of what we try and approach this
from is here our studio we try and solve
these problems in terms of creating
insights impacting decision making
maintain and improve over time things
that are difficult
by focusing on our three kind of core
tenets open source work
a code first mentality and centralized
or cloud-based kind of data science
environments and production
open source basically means widely used
eases recruiting retention and training
you have an entire massive community in
r and python creating content that you
can learn from
as well as libraries and different code
examples that you can adapt
code first meaning it's flexible you can
actually craft it into exactly what you
want there's not this black box
mentality where you just kind of plug
something in and get something back you
understand the process
and then centralized or cloud-based by
reducing the necessary work and
enhancing collaboration again i'm
working from a browser so i could access
my work from anywhere and collaborate
with my colleagues even though we're all
remote in this time
open source also means things like
comprehensive so based on community
contributions there's tens of thousands
of our packages on crayon and there's
tens of thousands of python libraries uh
across pi pi or other locations
code first also means you can
iterate quickly and update quickly and
you can adapt the code and understand by
just changing small portions
and then for centralized work your
deployment provides stakeholders
self-service access so you can actually
say here's the data product i've created
or the model that we're using and have
them actually interact with that as well
as have it work against say like your
website in production
and then lastly open source means
interoperable so you can break down some
of these analytic silos you're not stuck
with a specific vendor you can move
between clouds or even move between
products because you own the kind of
data science code that you've written
there in terms of you're able to adapt
it
code first meaning reusable and fully
extensible so again you can diff it you
can put into version control and check
all your changes and see what did we do
two years ago versus what we're doing
today
and lastly package management is
something that we're very keen on to
support again reproducibility and easing
the administration of open source data
science in your enterprise
so kind of summarizing this down we've
talked a little bit about these
different slides this serious data
science concept is summarized as open
source code first centralized
computation or a cloud environment the
leading languages that we're focused on
is are in python that's what we see the
most of the data science teams using
today and that's where we've built a lot
of our tooling around
and that's where our studio team comes
into play so our studio team is a suite
of all three of our professional
products our studio workbench which is
basically the r studio ide running in a
server as well as vs code and jupyter
for the python users
our studio connect for sharing insights
with decision makers via web apps emails
apis that are working production or
other different assets
and then our studio package manager
which is really the backbone between
those two products controlling managing
packages the data science need to create
and share their insights basically
making it where
even though you're
you know have all these different
libraries you're working with you're not
putting this program on i.t to figure
out how to manage that you as a data
scientist can kind of control your own
environment as you go along
so let's talk about this a little bit
more kind of practically we've talked
about bullet points but let's actually
show what this process looks like a
little bit
what we often see is this massive chasm
or this gap between the hard work that
the data science teams are doing and the
actual outcomes of that work so either
influencing decision makers or informing
them or making decisions as well as
automated decisions or things working
models in production things working on
your website things making decisions
automatically within your organization
or informing your organization
so let's talk about how we can kind of
bridge this gap
so data science teams are creating some
type of insights or sharing insights to
impact decision making whether this is
again interactive web applications
reports or
apis or other assets that are making
automated decisions through machine
learning
these data science teams are probably
wanting to use a data science workbench
where they can choose to work in their
primary language maybe it's r maybe it's
python maybe it's both they want to have
that flexibility of having all this
available ready to go in one environment
so they're building things that are in
python these assets need to live
somewhere there's tailored applications
that actually have a front end so the
decision makers can go and interact with
it
there's reports that need to go out kind
of automatically
there's apis that kind of again can work
against a website or other you know
software languages like java or scholar
or anything else
so these need to be published to a
deployment server basically somewhere to
host all these data science products
you're interacting with or creating
things that exist on this deployment
server can then be delivered again by
web apps and emails and reports that
inform decision makers when they need it
and they can actually have self-service
applications so they can kind of
understand what you're doing in your
data science role
but also having things like apis that
are working in production and integrate
into automated decision making in your
website or against other software inside
your company
now the last part of this puzzle you
know we've kind of made our way over to
influencing decisions whether uh true
human to human interaction or automated
is package management in terms of rn
python or open source libraries which is
their strength but you also need to
kind of manage those different
environments because the open source
landscape is changing over time so
package management is important for
easing maintenance as well as
reproducibility of your analyses over
time
now if we overlay exactly kind of what
we provide here at our studio this is
how it fits into the world we do have a
workbench environment in rstudio
workbench that allows you to analyze
data in r and in python we have r studio
connect that can host all the different
r products as well as many python
products so apis in r and in python via
plumber and flask
pins for data sets in our shiny
applications with interactive front ends
are marked down for reports websites or
even entire emails and other things
as well as jupiter streamlight dash fast
api bokeh and flask
so this rich kind of ability to publish
many different data science products in
rm python
i did see a question coming in the chat
about stata inside jupyter notebooks
that is something that in terms of our
markdown can actually support static
chunks other things we're primarily
focused on r and python but many of the
things that you use in jupiter notebooks
whether it's extensions or other things
can work inside our studio workbench as
well but we're primarily focused on r
and python
so
that's kind of you know a again a more
general example let's dive real quickly
into a real life example so this is an
example that lives at
solutions.studio.com
bike predict
and this is basically an end-to-end
example of the exact workflow i showed
before
but we've now replaced all those little
images with actual data science products
so the first part of your data science
workflow might be data import cleaning
fitting a model training a model you
know all the different things that
you're doing in your day-to-day work
this can be done inside our markdown and
with our studio connect you can host at
our markdown so you can reference in the
future or even schedule it to be
executed on some type of schedule so you
might do nightly model training or batch
training that goes against the database
and then saves back the model somewhere
in our example we will be pinning a
model as a pin here
i'll be going over some some demos here
in a second just kind of going through
some of the the highlights above
you can also save existing data sets so
say you do have a subset that you want
to pull into an application you can also
extract specific data sets and save them
as a pin or a data set living on our
studio connect
rcdo connect can connect to your
databases so you could have a live
database connection against either a
production database or one specifically
tailored just for your web applications
the
models will be served up as an api so
your model is trained it's saved and
then it's actually put into production
as an api via the plumber package
so this will then serve both a front end
that's interactive in terms of your
business users or your decision makers
can go to a shiny application and
interact with it and see how does the
model actually work and they can change
different parameters and see how it
changes but it's also working in
production in terms of like doing the
predictions for you on your site
a couple other uh talks or questions
coming in in terms of where the slides
are available the slides are available
at this link here at the bottom
colorado.studio.com
rstudio team prez
or you can find the slides on
my github at rstudio team demo so it's
going to be j thomas mock slash rstudio
dash team dash
demo and then lastly you see our studio
package manager over here supporting all
the different libraries you see that
there's at least five libraries in here
but in reality you have many other r
libraries that are existing in this
example now there's some questions in
the chat about python you know in terms
of like i want to do web apps i'm not as
big of a pipe as an r user i'm more
comfortable in python or vice versa we
also support a similar workflow or like
kind of this model management with
python in our studio
so here rather than using our markdown
maybe you're using a juice printer
notebook and rather than using a plumber
api to host your your model in
production you're using flask and then
to consume the model your api consumers
can actually query the flask api running
on connect and then your business users
could interact with the flask api with
plotly dash which is another dashboard
software or another kind of interactive
web application that we support
now this is still pretty high level in
terms of we're talking about mostly
pictures and different things but just
the goal here is that we're showing you
both r and python are supported inside
this environment
yes it can still interact with other
different softwares in terms of maybe
using a specific database like using
snowflake or postgres or you have a
spark cluster or databricks you can
interact with those different things
through the software as well because
you're using open source data science
you are able to actually use anything
you can do in r and python you're able
to leverage within the r studio team
stack so as long as you have an odbc
driver or a connection you can make you
can connect to all these different data
sources
now version control is another big thing
in here so if we go back like all these
different things you may not want to
like put those all up on the public so
you could actually source different
things from a private internal r package
for example
so maybe you write an internal r package
that you don't want to publish on crayon
because it's got internal code or it's
querying its internal databases you can
actually publish that package to our
studio package manager and never have to
you know expose it to the outside world
if you wanted to
you can also use things like azure
devops or bitbucket for you know offline
or
private or firewalled github integration
or
whatever you want to do all the
different kind of resources are
available there
all right so i know people are you know
itching to actually see some some more
live demos or some coding so i know i
started at the beginning by jumping into
our studio workbench and showing you a
quick example so let's go back there and
have a little bit of fun
so
the kind of the takeaway from the
initial uh part of the presentation was
i can take these slides that i needed to
rebuild and send them essentially
instantly to rstudio connect so that
ability to quickly iterate is very
powerful
you might notice that in this rstudio
environment i've got a couple new things
that aren't available in our studio
desktop because i'm running in the cloud
and because i'm running uh our studio
workbench as opposed to the open source
desktop version
number one i'm authenticated so for your
it team or for security reasons i'm
authenticated through single sign-on so
i have enterprise grade authentication
basically making sure that any of the
data that i'm working with is secure and
that all the different proprietary
things i'm working on are protected
i also have the ability to change my
version of r so i can switch from you
know r version 4.0 to the latest at
4.1.1
all sorts of great things you can do in
one session
uh the other benefit is because i'm
working in the cloud or i'm working
outside of my desktop is i'm no longer
tied to
a
specific kind of compute environment so
sure i've got a powerful laptop but my
cloud environment is almost always going
to be much much more powerful
so specifically you might have say like
an aws instance or an azure or you know
google cloud whatever different kind of
cloud provider you want to use is
supported
and you can actually have support for
things like kubernetes for additional
scaling
you may not be familiar with kubernetes
and that's okay it's not required what
that basically means is that i can
actually from within my session
run an additional background spirit
against the kubernetes cluster and have
that scale up as needed
so this option via the launcher job
actually allows me to specify the amount
of compute i want to do for this
background job i'm running
so i can run it with for a demo server
we're limited to three cpus but this
could be much larger in a production
environment and then i can change the
amount of ram that's available as well
now you might think that's kind of silly
it's like okay i don't want to run an
upload script as a background job but
what about some grid or model tuning
so this is a quick example of an
end-to-end kind of
long grid search so it's going across a
bunch of different hyper parameters
fitting a model and saving it out
of course i could run this in my
existing environment but that's going to
lock up my console i'm not able to kind
of continue working
so what i can do with rcdo workbench is
start a launcher job
it automatically pulls in the script i'm
working on so this tuning script that's
probably going to run for a while
i'll set it to the maximum of three cpus
and eight gigs of remembering
and then i'll start that
and now this is going to run in a
background environment and it's going to
return back examples as it goes along
i'm still able to use my primary
environment so i can still do my you
know my math or do any exploratory data
analysis or plotting but i have this
launcher job that's going in the
background and actually fail because of
uh
my my code had an issue in it in terms
of the model failed but it would run as
a background job in this case if i had
actually written the code correctly
you can also do local jobs so if you
didn't have access to a remote
kubernetes cluster you could actually
run it as a local job in terms of
running it on the same environment but
not having to exist on your you know
small cluster you could do on a bigger
one
all right so let's take one step back
real quick
so i've been focusing only mostly on our
studio work revenge
our studio workbench might look a little
bit different than your r studio
environment so i started in our studio
so we could be comfortable and now we're
going to back a little bit out
so our studio team
our studio ide here this is where i just
was so i backed out to the kind of home
page landing page which has a few
different projects i'm working on
as well as jupiter notebook and a vs
code session
again because we're trying to support
both r and python workflows or a mix of
those workflows we also have support for
things like jupyter notebooks
so i can open up a jupyter notebook
inside our studio workbench with the
exact same authentication
i still have my home directory that is
you know embedded here so all the files
that are available to me in rstudio and
r are also available to me
in jupyter or vs code so i can open up
the team demo
there's a jupyter notebook here i can
open up that jupyter notebook
so let's let that load real quick
again i didn't have to you know set
anything else up i just am working from
inside our studio workbench i now have a
jupiter notebook and i'm running python
code in here
so here is the output from just reading
in a quick data set and getting a
summary of the different columns i can
create a quick graphic in matplotlib and
look at that
and then i can get the raw data as a
table here
all this in kind of an interactive
notebook that i wanted to use
all behind my authentication
now when i mentioned authentication i
said single sign-on but we support a lot
more than that we also support things
like ldap or saml other different active
directory or azure active directory
support so again most of the enterprise
grade authentication they might use in
your organization are supported here and
i just have to log in one time and then
i have access to all these different
environments
i can also take this jupyter notebook
and publish it to rstudio connect
so i can take the document
i'm going to include a couple other
things i'll include the
our markdown html and the
zipped data
and zoom out just a hair
and then i'll publish that to run
and so we'll publish the
notebook real quick over there
and then that's going to actually live
and it's going to deploy the notebook
onto our studio connect
so importantly you can publish the
finished document or the source document
so both in our markdown and in jupiter
you can publish these documents and
actually have them re-run on a schedule
or just post the finished document so
that you can actually interact with them
and rerun them in the future
so if i go to rstudio connect
that's where all my content is going to
live so we can actually let that pop up
in a second we've got a lot of cool
content on our studio connect so it'll
take a little bit to load
and we can look at the content i own
so right here this is the demo or the
actual slides i was using for today and
then we can see the jupiter notebook
that i was actually working on published
rstudio connect as well and again very
quickly in just you know under a minute
i was able to get the notebook i was
working on
interactively onto rstudio connect and
now i can share it with specific users
in my enterprise
while we're here inside our studio
connect and looking at a notebook
you'll notice that it defaults to
opening up the access portal
so with regards to authentication this
basically means once i'm authenticated
in i can do things but i also want to
open up access to specific users or to
specific you know within my entire
company
so it defaults to basically only i can
see the content that i've published
which is a good idea like maybe you
don't want to release it to the whole
company because it has sensitive data
i can add specific people like maybe i
want to add my colleague alex who can
see this document because i need his
review on it or i need the entire
solutions team to look at this and give
me feedback on the document our studio
connect because it's plugged into your
enterprise grade auth is able to you
know pull in these existing groups so
you don't have to do the work as a data
scientist to figuring out how does
authentication work that's baked in and
when you set up the software and set up
the server it'll actually integrate with
your existing authentication
of course if you just wanted to have it
available to anyone in the org you could
always save it
and make it where it's available to all
users login required basically as long
as they authenticate they can access it
or for what i did with the slides so
that you all could actually see it
i made it where anyone in the world
could see it so i made it anyone can see
it no login required
and it's got some more info so i can
look at like the screenshot of it i can
see okay about a hundred people have
viewed it today so that's great and uh a
lot of good interest in it so far
so we showed a quick jupiter notebook
it's interactive we publish it to
connect and we were able to kind of
control the authentication around it
but let's go one step further so let's
say that we want to you know we're not
wanting to work inside jupiter notebook
we actually want to work in say vs code
as we're a python developer and we want
kind of a full-blown ide as opposed to a
specific notebook
so i've logged into
vs code again it's using my existing
authentication so i've logged into our
studio workbench and then i can hop
directly into vs code
it's got again my whole home directory
so all the files that are available in r
are available in vs code here as well
i've opened up that same jupiter
notebook so we're going to stick with
the jupyter notebook example because
they've got a nice
interaction
inside vs code but
let's clear all the cells real quick
so we cleared all the cells
and then we can run
let's trust this one real quick and we
can actually run the code in each of
these and interact with these cells
inside vs code
while that's loading and connecting the
different kernel it's connecting to
python 3.7.5 it's basically making a
reply or a read eval print loop
basically saying like i can interact
with python live so it has to do that
for the first time when we set up the
environment once that's set up it'll go
pretty quickly
so we get the same table and i could
always say well rather than a year
let's make it 365 days and rerun that
and now it says 52 week 365 days we can
do our our plot
and we get our matplotlib plot and we
can print out the raw data as well here
so still the ability to do that within
vs code
and because we've embedded things like
jupiter and jupiter lab and vs code
inside of here you can fully customize
it so you can extend it with the
extensions you'd like or
other kind of integrations that you want
to show
and i can always go back to our studio
if i want to get out of here and go back
to r
i can go back to my home page and go
directly back into our studio team and
i'm ready to go back here
all right
so
still within our studio and we're to
we've published some python products
we've published in our products let's
show a quick example of using r and
python inside our studio so you may not
know this but you can actually use r and
python chunks inside our studio so this
will actually use a library called
reticulate which is a kind of a play on
words for reticulated python this allows
you to call python code from r
so i'll run this it's got my python
environment running and then inside in
our markdown notebook i can get this
similar output to what we're seeing
inside our jupiter notebook
we have the exact same kind of table
that we're doing with year and again i
can change this from year to 365 days
and re
and re-execute the whole thing
get that so now it's 365 days we can
i'll clear the plot so we can recreate
it
we can create a plot in line
and we can get the raw data as a table
inside our studio you can actually see
both r and python objects
so the r
is just showing the connection to a
postgres database but python actually
has the prices data frame and you can
explore that here
now
this might be a little bit kind of
overwhelming it's like all these
different things going on
again our studio workbench is providing
this front end to all these different
environments so our studio workbench
provides rstudio the ide you know and
love and that you're very comfortable in
if you're a python user maybe you prefer
jupiter notebooks or vs code and that's
fine we support those as well so all
this is done within our studio workbench
now the data products you create in
terms of our markdown reports jupyter
notebooks um flask apis plumber apis
shiny apps dash apps bokeh streamlit all
these different things you're creating
an rm python those all get published to
rstudio connect so you're doing all of
your coding initially in workbench once
you've created something then you host
and publish it on rstudio connect
so we've shown the different parts of
our studio team in terms of the ide the
notebooks and then vs code
and we've shown a little bit of this
running in rstudio connect so
let's close down a few of these things
so we're not quite as overwhelmed we've
got that up we can close
the vs code environment
and then we've got a couple other
different things here so let's open up
my portfolio dashboard so this is
actually a shiny application running on
our studio connect
i can show publishing this again in a
second but we've already seen a bit of
the publishing workflow
so this might look like most shiny apps
you've seen you know it's got some
different parameters on the side you can
look at it's got some built-in
interactivity through i believe the dui
graphs are packaged so you can or no
this is actually plotly so you can
actually see the hover on different bars
and then you can change parameters and
the graphics will update in place
based on the changes you're making shiny
so that all makes sense
again we have access to specific users
or
uh you know changing who can actually
view these applications
but with all the interactive web apps so
if you think of like shiny and r or dash
and streamlit in python
those are actually server based products
so they actually have a r or a python
runtime behind it
so what our studio connect provides is
as a data scientist
you probably don't want to worry you
know figure out how do i run a linux box
how do i scale things automatically how
do i set up you know parallel work or
multiple r or python processes like
that's not necessarily where you want to
spend your time
that's what our studio connect does for
you so it provides the ability to scale
up the you know scale up the actual
server or the actual compute environment
as more users come to visit it
so if we read this this basically says
this shiny application can spin up three
separate r processes that can each serve
20 connections
so this shiny application just out of
the gate can serve 60 people now i could
change these parameters and make it
serve 100 or a thousand or in some cases
we have examples of like tens of
thousands of users that could be
potentially supported
that's going to be based around how big
your server is but you as the data
scientist don't have to worry about how
does this actually scale in terms of
figuring out all the different
components you have the ability to just
publish your shiny application and then
change in these parameters if you need
to
you can also set things like the timeout
so some map trying applications or dash
applications run for a little while so
you can actually delay the timeout so
that you know it doesn't kick off in the
middle of something that's executing but
for most of the time these are very
quick in terms of you saw like i can
change something and in like a second or
two it's going to change the actual
component because it's going to rerun
the r code or the python code
and this is supported for both r and
python content so that was shiny we can
do the exact same workflows for python
based content as well so let's go to
the quick dash application
and
let's do this dash application for my
colleague david
so this is just one of the examples from
the dash team in terms of like their
hello world examples but a rich one that
they have
and again i have the ability to change
these parameters as i see fit so as a
data scientist i can publish my
application
i can change different things and it
makes the graphic change on its own
but i don't have to worry about how does
linux work or how does authentication
work or how does scaling of an
environment work
i just get to create the data science
content that i want to put out there
so we've talked a bit about shiny and
dash you do similar things with
streamlets let's close down a few of
these little ones
here's a streamlit example streamlet's
very similar to like a shiny based our
markdown
um in terms of they're kind of like a
notebook style setup or a linear flow
but the same idea in that you change
your parameter and then the code is
re-executed to regenerate something in
this case showing an output
uh or a graphic but this is running uh
python on the back end as well
you could create something similar to
this in our markdown with a shiny
runtime that's also supported on our
studio connect
and again you have full access to the
access controls
as well as the runtime for changing the
parameters of how how much it scales
the other benefit in terms of
reproducibility is let's see if uh
let's go back to one of mine
so
i have a presentation on production
databases
we can look that i actually have
multiple versions of this presentation
so i publish an older one at the very
end of september and actually go back to
a previous version
so i can maintain or i can overwrite so
let's say i have a presentation that i'm
building or our markdown report or
jupiter report i'm building
connect will handle the history of that
report
in terms of showing you like oh i can
look at older versions of the same thing
so i can always look at the latest if i
wanted to but i could roll back to an
older version if i wanted to show that
to someone else be like what were things
looking like a month ago or six months
ago or the last time i ran the report
and all of that is kind of built into
connect and you have the ability to make
it where it doesn't keep any of the
history if it's going to be really big
and you don't want to store all those or
you can store many many versions of the
same report over and over
all right
so let's close down some more of these
little guys this is another dash
application running on connect
another one you might worry about is
within a data science team maybe you're
not creating as much content that's
consumed by business users and that's
okay like in terms of like you're
creating tooling for your internal team
or you're
creating knowledge repositories or
knowledge sharing within your data
science team
this is an our markdown report hosted on
our studio connect
that aggregates multiple data science
things within an entire project
so if we scroll down this is that
end-to-end workflow i showed in the
slides from earlier which is bringing
some data in
creating some data sets that are saved
to rstudio connect as a pin
taking a model and saving it onto our
studio connect and then serving that
model up as an api that's interacting
with shiny applications or website
so this aggregates all those different
components so as a data scientist sure
i'm probably going to have some of this
on version control and that's where i'm
going to be like actually writing code
but if i want to just go interact with
the things in production this shows me
all the different components of this
very complex data science task so the
etl scripts you know these are scheduled
to re-execute every you know every 15
minutes or every day so that i need to
check to see if those are going well and
what the output was
there's modeling in terms of the scoring
of the of the model and how well it did
or the training of the xg boost model
and then it actually can send out an
email report if something goes awry so
our studio connect has support for email
servers so if a parameter is met or is
not met it can actually send you an
email and in line in that email embed
gigiplot or a table or attach a csv or
attach a presentation or attach a report
whatever you want to do in r you can
kind of build that into a presentation
and send it along
it then goes along and has the different
data sets that this is using so it's
pinning from a database into these these
kind of extracted data sets
it's got a link out to the specific api
the performance app which is intended
for the data scientist to interact with
the api and then the kind of production
uh you know business user focused api
interaction so they can actually click
on it with shiny or with dash
so a lot of cool things going on here
let's dive real quick though in terms of
one of the things that resonates for me
and what i use a lot is scheduling of
content
so let's actually we'll go back and go
to the etl
i often have tasks where you know it's
something i have to do all the time
and i i want it to re-run on a schedule
i don't have to manually pull from the
database click run and then publish to
connect like that that sounds like
a lot of me clicking a lot of buttons so
what i can do instead
is for this
portion in terms of its connecting to
rcdo connect and the database it's
cleaning the data and then writing out
the data i can actually schedule this to
run every single day so built into
connect i can say schedule this output
re-run this exact code at this time
every day and publish the output
so it's going to go through and if we
look at the history there's many many
different versions of this report
because it's been running every single
day
so this report runs every day does some
type of cleaning or automate some type
of model training step that i don't have
to do manually so now i can go spend my
time on other things that are more
useful in my time rather than clicking
run every day or rewriting something
manually every day
and importantly because it's on rstudio
connect the package environment is
stable
so while my dev environment i can
install new packages and i can change my
version of r once i publish something to
rstudio connect it's stable in terms of
its
living there it's got its own little
environment that's controlled with a
very specific version of
very specific version of all these
different packages that is static and
it's controlled
so this report has been running for i
think over a year and i have other
reports have been running on our studio
connect for since i've joined our studio
over three years ago so it's nice to be
able to put something in production and
just let it run even though my dev
environment where i'm writing new code
has changed or the you know the actual
outside world has changed a bit
um the
as far as the emails that get sent out
so you can see there's like an email
button here there's an email that's sent
out every time this is executed and it's
sent to the person who published it so
in this case alex gets a report every
day saying hey this ran successfully and
here's the output
but i can also send it to all of my
collaborators so anyone who's also
working on this package or on this
project can get a copy
of the
of the report
i can click manually send this in terms
of email report to me right now even
though you know the thing hasn't been
scheduled right now send it to me right
now
and you can control you know basically
how it shows up with the latest release
of our studio connect you can kind of
control saying like this is coming from
our studio connect or coming you know
sending it to whoever you want inside
your organization so again your
authentication is talking to that email
server and as long as your people exist
in your authentication database you can
send these emails to them
all right so we're getting close to the
1043 so i want to make sure that we
cover the last component
so a lot of cool things i could talk
about
our studio connect basically all day but
i do want to talk a little bit about our
studio package manager because it's kind
of the unsung hero
behind all of this
so the amazing part of the r and python
ecosystems is not only do they have an
amazing kind of core language and base
packaging available within them but the
package ecosystem that extends the
capabilities
so again there's tens of thousands of
packages available all of which can have
many different versions so from an i.t
perspective they get nervous when they
hear open source sometimes because
they're like oh you know i can't control
it how do i manage this
package manager allows you to store an
entire copy of crayon behind your
firewall air gapped on your environment
so let's say for ggpod for example which
i've pulled up here
our version of package manager
internally we're using has the latest
version as well as the archived versions
going back to 2007.
so if i needed to if i had a very old
script i could install a binary
pre-compiled version of this library
from 2007 and install it
that binary component is really
important inside linux packages
actually have to be built but we provide
binaries that are pre-compiled so this
means that rather than taking like an
hour to install a package it's almost
instantaneous because you're just
downloading the package and installing
it rather than compiling it from source
so that's another
benefit that
packs manager provides
you can also see here on the left we
have different repositories or
collections of packages so this
basically means we're able to curate
specific uh aggregations of packages and
what they look like
so i could have internal only for
packages that we've reached and written
inside like our studio that aren't
public or for your organization
packages that you're writing to do very
specific things that you don't
necessarily want to make fully available
and you're just using internally
and then packs manager also supports pi
pi so you can make a copy of pi
and let's see if we can get pandas and
we can get pandas we can get the latest
version of 1.3.3
as well as older versions going back to
older releases so again both r and
python support
um
there's a question about integration
with tableau stay uh stay posted there's
some hopefully exciting news coming out
quickly and then for team of government
consultants able to adopt the whole tool
chain internally but able to deploy a
potentially sensitive data dashboard for
clients
so what we see a lot with teams that
have multiple constituencies is you can
either run
uh multiple servers so like some groups
have an internal rstudio connect or
internal or steel workbench and then
they have another version that's
actually for external use so again you
can either have people
completely in a completely separate
environment so there's no chance of
exposure of data or reports or you can
add them into your authentication group
and just allow them to see very specific
components of very specific reports
um
[Music]
in terms of
scheduling that can be done there's
another question about that so
scheduling can be done down to the
minute or up to the year so it doesn't
have to be daily it could be every five
or ten minutes
um and you can
you know have it run however frequently
you want
as far as package manager it can support
crayon as well as bioconductor or github
so yes you could have a package that
only exists on github you can install it
onto our studio package manager or for
example if you had an internally
developed package that didn't exist
anywhere else you can also install that
locally on your rstudio package manager
without exposing it to the world
so
we're last few minutes here i've
answered a few questions so let's dive
back into the presentation to wrap it up
and then i'll stick around
longer than the top of the hour and
continue answering questions as long as
folks want to
so let's dive back into this there's
still some more components here that i
want to talk about
so we got to
the live demo portion and we're going to
talk real briefly about some of these
other components and then i'll answer
some more questions
so while i'm really excited about our
studio team and all the different
amazing things they can do
we often you want to hear from what do
your peers think about this so if you go
to our customer stories pane which again
is linked here we can go to rstudio.com
about slash customer stories
you can read about what other data
science teams have done with our
products basically how they've used our
studio to harness the full capabilities
of their data science team or streamline
their deployment process or merge
software engineering and data science
without making it painful for everyone
to interact with it
so these are actual real life stories of
how other people out in the wild and
your peers are using our products
if you'd rather just kind of read
summaries or reviews these are you know
public reviews on trustradius.com
and these are all verifieds this means
that they're in their customers we're
not able to kind of influence them
they're just putting it up here in trust
radius
people talking about a mix of arm python
on our studio
or how our studio products are great for
their technical teams and their business
team members
integration of both languages helps them
out a lot in terms of being able to be
productive
and a lot of people use r studio connect
as they're like one stop shop for
publishing so documents apps apis you
have a clean professional interface uh
where you can work with all your
different clients and stakeholders
internally along with your
authentication and along with all of
your kind of professional database
products
so if we think about our studio team
it's really a modular platform so you
can always choose one of these if that's
all you needed some teams only have
workbench some teams only have connect
some teams have connect and package
manager
if you get them all together there's
actually a bundle discount but you can
always purchase them individually if
that was the only data product you
needed but importantly this is
complementing your existing analytic
investments you know every organization
has different needs every organization
has all sorts of different data products
or kind of integrations that they want
to bring to the table
so your corporate data all the different
databases you're using things like spark
or distributed computing basically any
database that you can connect to through
odbc and rm python you can pull into our
studio workbench or rstudio connect
you can also connect to those
distributed environments so someone had
mentioned data brick so db connect is a
great example of being able to send
compute into giant you know clusters in
spark and then pull down the results
into say a shiny application
you can also connect to external job
management clusters this is not required
in terms of you don't have to be
kubernetes native or if you don't know
what that word means that's okay but
kubernetes is basically a way of doing
elastic scaling of your environment so
rather than having a traditional server
that has a set amount of ram and memory
kubernetes allows you to spin up new
compute as needed and then shrink back
down
and that's supported inside our studio
workbench where you can actually you
know send out those large jobs to be
executed and then close down the
environment so you're not paying for it
all the time
you can connect to other data science
tools so again because you're using r
and python and these are open source
data science languages you don't only
have to use them inside these products
just we think they're great environments
for that
r and python can be used anything else
maybe you also have a docker-based
workflow or you have other data science
products that use are and python we're
not changing any of the r and python
open source in terms of we're just
contributing open source software but
we're not flavoring it where it only
works on here and doesn't work on there
you can take those open source work that
you've done and use it anywhere so
you're not locked in or limited to
proprietary formats
you can also connect to things like
reporting or bi tools so a lot of the
team a lot of the time there's actually
separation between your business
intelligence team and your data science
team
what we're seeking to do here is make
connections or support between those so
maybe you have an automated job on our
studio connect that updates data that
the bi team uses
so rather than your business
intelligence analyst coming to data
scientists for ad hoc request they have
a self-service or automated tool getting
that data fitting those models
doing some type of work in our python
that they can then just consume or adapt
and then you have obviously like your
tailored decision support so you can
create those eight those web apps in
dash or shiny or streamlit or reports in
our markdown that can be you know
accessed by c-level executives or other
data science you know uh decision makers
within your organization
and then lastly you have full support
for these automated decisions or the
ability to you know publish restful apis
in r and python that integrate into any
other software
now in terms of closing out part of the
presentation for today and something
that i'm again very passionate about is
what makes our studio different as a
company
our mission and kind of our purpose for
existing is actually creating free and
open source software for data science
scientific research and technical
communication
basically we want to make sure that we
allow anyone with access to computer to
participate freely in a data-centric
global economy we want to enhance the
production and consumption of knowledge
and we want to facilitate collaboration
and reproducible research and science
education industry
so this is why we create so much open
source software and why more than 50 of
all of our engineering resources go to
free and open source software things
like all the tidy verse or the r
packages we release some of the new
support that we're doing for for python
in terms of contributing either
financially or with code to other python
products
so overall revenue from our pro products
goes into funding our open source so
that we can essentially achieve this
mission
so we're ecstatic if you can you know
get everything done with our open source
software that's one of our goals is that
you can be extremely productive with all
of our software
for some organizations that need things
like authentication or scaling those
problems are not necessarily like data
science problems we're solving i.t or
administration and data science problems
so there's this interaction between our
professional software funding our open
source efforts for the world
additionally we're a public benefit corp
so this was announced at the uh 2020
rstudio conf so if you haven't seen that
video i highly recommend going looking
at keynote jj elaire our ceo and founder
basically helped convert our studio from
an incorporated organization to a b
corporation or a public benefit
corporation
so this basically means that our open
source mission is codified or built into
our company charter so any decisions we
make must balance the best interest of
our community customers employees and
the different shareholders so definitely
something i'm very proud of and if you
have a chance i would highly look at
this rstudio.com
pdc keynote to read more about that
so i'll stick around for some more
questions but if you just want to kind
of read some links or do some things you
can read all about serious data science
and r studio team with these links again
this us presentation is available at
colorado.rstudio.com
rsc
rstudio dash team prez
if you want to know more about what
actual r studio team users think you can
read our reviews at trust radius those
are all the public reviews of our
product from customers
if you do want to chat and get specific
questions answered or you wanted to talk
about something and you didn't feel
comfortable asking in a group setting
you can always book a live meeting with
us and we can connect you with one of
our our experts internally and we can
talk about whatever you need to again no
strings attached just let's have a
conversation
and then lastly maybe you don't even
want to have a meeting you just want to
evaluate the product so you want to be
like okay this looks cool but i want to
actually try it out myself you actually
go and evaluate our studio team today in
a hosted environment you can go actually
request this and try it out in the cloud
uh no strings attached no no purchase
necessary and try things out
um i have a few more minutes left i've
been trying to answer questions as they
come in
um but i'm going to try and go back and
see if there's a few different questions
um
about
different things let me go through those
um
yes so a good really good question is
connect completely cloud-based or do we
have to do on-prem and get our it group
involved you have the choice so in terms
of we think of
going back to here
you can install this on bare metal
servers behind your firewall on premise
lots of customers do that that's great
we fully support that you can also
install it in a cloud of your choosing
so aws google cloud azure ibm wherever
you want to install it
the only requirement here is that you're
installing in a linux environment so
wherever that linux environment lives is
fine just a linux environment so if you
want to do on-premise that's great if
you want to do in the cloud that's great
as well
the question about scripts being
triggered say on new data available
you can build in logic to your uh
re-running of the script so basically
you can have it you know check every 15
minutes or something and be like is new
data available it's checking on it and
if no then stop if yes then rerun we are
evaluating the idea of like true logic
based scheduling built in our studio
connect so if you are interested in that
please reach it out and kind of help us
you know promote that idea for now it's
scheduled based on a time base but you
can integrate some of that logic into
the code within the script
so they want to use that scheduling
function but how to check daily results
so one of the things is like as the
admin time
or as the admin of the server what i can
look at is i can see all the different
things that are scheduled so this was a
good customer request in terms of like i
schedule something and i didn't realize
it was every minute it's like oh geez i
want to look at this and be like why is
this happening every minute sometimes
that's actually necessary and you can
take a look at like okay this is
occurring every 10 minutes maybe i
should check on it and check with ian
about if that's supposed to be scheduled
as long
or i can just look at all the different
kind of things and when they're
scheduled and what i can do with this
view is actually separate out
computationally intensive portions so
like model training to occur overnight
so say like between midnight and 5 am
i do all this computation when no one is
using the server and then at 6 am to 5
pm
that's when i leave computation
available for business users to come in
and interact with my applications
perfect so
i know another question was about if the
there's a link to
the github repo so if you did want to
look at some of the examples i showed in
terms of these are actual code examples
that you can play around with
if you go to my github at j thomas mock
slash rstudio dash team-demo
that has all of the different resources
i showed today and has a link to some of
the other portions of what we covered
today as well as the
slides i'm going to try and see if
there's any other questions i got to
move around some pages
tanya any other questions that came in
or any other links you'd like me to
share
get those pulled over
pull this up go back in the workbench
no okay i think that's all the questions
for today but if you do have more
questions please do reach out to us
again
if you go to uh
the last page of this you can actually
schedule a meeting or reach out directly
or you can reach us at sales rstudio.com
with with general queries and we can
always talk to you by email if you'd
rather not have a live meeting but we're
very passionate about talking to
customers and hearing from y'all or
potential folks in terms of like what
types of things you need to do in your
organization to be successful so please
do reach out if you have any questions
with that thank you so much oh one more
question coming in
uh does our studio connect still require
root level privileges to run
so our studio connect if you're talking
about like running connect inside a
docker container it still requires root
level privileges but if you want to talk
further about that please do reach out
we're have some very exciting kind of
work happening in that area
so if you're interested in kind of
talking a bit deeper about root level
privileges please open up and chat to us
and we can talk about it
let's see if i can pull up uh
got to pull up the one page
thanks so much for kind of learning with
me today um we're still kind of
evaluating what
you know how to best to use some of
these youtube live events so if you do
have feedback please
uh you know kind of reach out about that
i'm going to look and see if there's um
any more questions i appreciate the
thank yous
um let's see
yeah and then some questions for tonya
again if you want to evaluate there's
the link that was dropped in the chat
about the evaluation
still got a hundred and something people
in the chat so if you have any more
questions please keep them coming uh
otherwise i can kind of drop off here in
a few minutes but thank you so much with
uh
with your questions today
i'm very excited about this kind of
stuff so thanks for kind of learning
along with me and
uh enjoying this youtube live event with
us
i see one more question coming in so
i'll give that one a second to roll
yeah so there's a question i don't want
to steal the thunder but you know we've
had a couple questions about tableau so
let's let's talk a little bit about that
um
so let's go back to content
so yes in short we we do have
integrations there's the shiny tableau
package which is a way of embedding
shiny into um
into rco connect as well as interacting
with tableau
and
i actually have an example of some
content we're working on internally on
making those connections
so the
plumber tableau package for r or the
fast api tableau package for python
actually allow you to directly create
restful apis in r or in python that
directly connect with tableau via the
tableau analytics extensions so this is
kind of a first class citizen of r and
python running within tableau and again
trying to merge those ideas of data
science teams and business intelligence
teams working happily together as
opposed to being at odds with uh not
being able to
you know not be able to interact
together and not be able to like work
together cleanly so these two packages
are very exciting so basically full r
and python support uh for analytics
extensions and tableau and those can be
hosted on our studio connect just like
the other kind of data products we
showed today
um
question one more connect servers failed
support email um
yes so if you have a question about
email please do reach out to support
ourstudio.com
and we have some resources around that
um another question about power bi
um so power bi i believe actually has a
support for restful apis so without even
having to do anything special just using
plumber and r or fast api
or um
you know flask in python you could
actually call that from a power bi
notebook so as long as you can query a
api in terms of we think about the
apologies for bouncing around a little
bit trying to get back to this
presentation so i can show
a quick example so bear with me for a
second thanks for your patience
but i see you asked that twice want to
make sure i get you a good answer
uh let's look at this so our studio tune
demo
so the the short answer is
so these apis if you think of it like an
api is just an endpoint that exists and
can be queried from anything that can
communicate with it so my understanding
is that things like power bi or other
software can actually interact directly
with those apis and just perform a query
so you could actually have an api
written in r or python
living on rstudio connect and then
you're querying it in things like even
excel i believe that excel even has
support for for some api capabilities
um maybe that's not the
ideal workflow but
it is definitely definitely possible
um
starting to lose a few people so i know
we're about four minutes over so thank
you again so so much for for joining me
today it's always a pleasure to kind of
connect with the community um thanks for
taking the hour out of your day to hang
out with me for a while um definitely if
you want to stick around for other
things our data science hangouts are
happening and those are great for more
kind of informal discussions we're just
talking a bit more about data science
and being a data science practitioner
but uh thank you so much and if you have
further questions please do reach out to
us here at our studio always happy to
chat
other than that have a great weekend
stay safe and thank you for your time